So, next we're talking with Elaine
Fontaine who's director of Data Quality
and Analytics at the Rhode Island
Quality Institute in CurrentCare.
Thank you very much for
being with us today.
>> Thanks for having me.
>> We all know, Elaine, that we
need new financial models to make
healthcare work the way
we'd like it to work.
The students are quite familiar with
that from earlier lessons in the course.
And they recognize that those are
intimately tied to quality reporting and
quality improvement.
So, can you tell us the things that
CurrentCare is doing to support
providers here in Rhode Island
to achieve those things?
>> So I think that we are currently
providing actually outside of
CurrentCare data, quality data
management on reporting services for
the Chronic Care
Sustainability Initiative,
which is Rhode Island's
patient-centered medical home project.
And for that project, we're actually
collecting and aggregating data on
about 15 quality measures that
are sort of related to meaningful use.
We're also doing
utilization reporting and
patient experience through the patients
under medical home caps survey which is
what NCQA requires of those practices.
And with those data we're really sort
of looking, grouping them up and
aggregating them in
a variety of ways to help
the practices see their
performance over time.
And assess their success with
regard to improving the quality and
reducing costs which is
of course not that easy.
But we think that the differences
in the data sources associated with
what's available to the HIE,
relative to what's available to a EMR,
relative to what's available
in a claims data set.
All of which are trying to be used for
this same purpose of looking at cost and
quality really can potentially result
in different answers to the same
questions because the populations
are a little bit different.
So for example, we're working on
a chlamydia screening analyses.
And I'll be presenting it, Amy,
in November of this year, in 2014, to
look at the differences in those rates
between those three population groups.
So commercial payer will have
a different result than a Medicaid payer
which will have a different result
than what's coming out of the EMR and
the HIE.
So we're trying to understand those
differences before we report them
publicly from the perspective of
here's how you do a better job taking
good care of quality
docs in the community.
>> So, is it fair to assume that
the HIE does serve to help collect and
help aggregate the data so
that you can do this quality report?
>> I feel like we're really pretty
nascent in that regard, and so
these chlamydia screening rates
are our first entry into it, but I'm
pretty sensitive to the idea that we
need to understand those differences.
Is it that we as the HIE have
a sub-selective population which
might have a higher screening rate or a
lower screening rate than another group.
Are we including the uninsured,
which are not really represented
in anybody else's measures.
So until we sort of dig into that and
really are able to benchmark against
known metrics, I'm reticent to sort of
just say here's the real answer for
the population of Rhode Island.
And I think that's the goal and I feel
confidant we're going to get there.
But, it's one that we
need to move cautiously
in that regard because
the worst possible thing to do
is to report data without really
understanding what it means.
I think that you can do that
in some situations where
it's sort of marketing, but quality and
cost analytics are not marketing.
And when you're presenting
information that would reflect how
a provider is performing.
You need to make sure you have their
full engagement and input in how that
measure is calculated, and they need to
be able to be very, very confident of
its accuracy before you report it
>> Half the students remember these
comments when we, later on in the
course, we get into quality reporting,
and I try to show that it sounds great,
but it isn't so easy to do.
>> Yes, it's really quite
challenging without a doubt.
>> But it sounds like your long
goal is to have a unified statewide
population in public health
electronic reporting system for
the whole state of Rhode Island.
Is that where you're heading?
>> It is absolutely where we're heading.
And I believe, I have utmost confidence
that we're going to be there,
and I feel like we talk internally
a lot about where we are today
is light years behind where we're
going to be in six months and
it's light years ahead of
where we were six months ago.
I feel like the progress
is really rapid, and
I think that's in large part due
to a high degree of interest.
As coming full circle to
the beginning of your question,
the provider community is
becoming more and more interested
in these data because they are being
held accountable for them.
The Accountable Care Organization
news releases that the cycle
moving very rapidly.
We've just seen in the last three weeks,
three or
four announcements in
the news of payer provider
arrangements that are outside of
Medicare so that's pretty interesting.
>> So, one quick final question.
We look in the course
at some of the public
quality metrics that the Indiana
Health Information Exchange posts
through their
Quality Health First Initiative.
Are you doing that sort of thing here,
and what's the reaction from providers
to that idea if you are doing it?
>> So, I think that we have not been so
public yet.
I think that too is a progression coming
back to really needing provider buy in,
and so we're presenting that data
to providers on their groups.
Not at the provider level yet even.
And that's a real challenge
with regard to N anyway, but
we are presenting that to the group
of practices that are participating
in the patient-centered medical home
initiative, where they can actually
see their performance relative to their
peers in other healthcare settings.
But that's what reported publicly
at this point is the aggregate
of all of those programs relative to
the non-patients center medical home
data that's available in the state.
So, it's a process.
>> Well thank you very much for
taking the time to be with us.
>> My pleasure.